>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.,
>> Good afternoon and welcome
to the African American
[inaudible] Division.
I am Mary Jane Deeb, Chief of
the Division, and I'm delighted
to see you all here to attend
this special presentation
with Harry Boonin, who will
talk to us about his new book,
Never Tell a Boy Not to Fight.
As I always do, I make a little
presentation about our division,
and our division is made up of
three sections, the African,
the Near East, and
the Hebraic Sections.
We are responsible for materials
from 78 countries in the Near East,
Central Asia, the Caucuses, and
well as from the entire continent
of Africa, north and
south sub-Sahara,
and for the Hebraic
section we collect materials
from all over the world.
We are also very active
in acquiring materials,
and restore our materials,
we develop our collections,
we brief our visitors, and
we serve the collections
in this reading room.
We also invite scholars, and
experts, who have done research
and used our collections to share
their insights and their findings
with our patrons, with
our audiences here
in the United States,
and across the world.
And we like to have especially
authors who have written new books
and done research, to share, not
only the content of their research,
but how they've done their research.
So we are particularly happy
to welcome Harry Boonin today,
because he is making a presentation
on a topic that we rarely,
if ever, discuss at the Library.
Namely, boxing.
But Harry Boonin is a local
historian from Philadelphia,
whose work is, in many ways, unique,
as it focuses on boxers who came
from the Jewish Quarter
of Philadelphia.
As I looked Harry up on Google,
I found a little announcement
about this project.
That was before the
book had been written,
where he introduces himself, and
then adds, "I'm looking for stories,
letters, diaries, photographs of
the lesser known Jewish fighters,
managers, such as Phil Glassman,
Boo Boo Hoff, love the name,
trainers such as Kudel
Seinfeld, and sports writers,
such as Lou Jaffe, of Philadelphia.
Any personal stories
or personal content
to families would be
greatly appreciated.
The moment you read this,
you really are excited.
You want to know-did
people give the letters?
Did they share their photographs?
You know, who are the
people, the stories?
I mean it's a hook that immediately
makes you want to read the book,
and to know how that
book got written.
So I am sure he is going to share
with us a history and the story
of the boxer that he
is writing about.
But now, our very own Sharon
Horowitz, Senior Reference Librarian
in The Hebraic Section will
introduce Harry Boonin,
and the program.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Mary-Jane.
On behalf of the Hebraic
section, let me thank you all
for coming to today's program.
My name is Sharon Horowitz,
I'm the reference librarian
in the Hebraic Section.
The Hebraic Section marks its
beginning in 1912, with the receipt
of 10,000 Hebrew books
and pamphlets,
whose purchase was
made possible by a gift
from a New York Philanthropist,
Jacob Schiff,
from those humble beginnings,
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items.
In Hebrew, Yiddish,
Ladino, Judeo-Persian,
and other Hebraic script languages.
The Hebraic section also includes
an important collection of books
in the languages of Gez,
Amharic, and Tigrinya,
languages of Ethiopia,
past and present.
Our section's holdings
are particularly strong
in the subject areas of Bible and
Rabbinic liturgy, Hebrew language,
and literature response
and Jewish history.
Two of our missions in this division
are to publicize our collections,
and to bring people
into the library,
and one way we accomplish this
second goal is by holding lectures,
and having programs, such as the one
we are hosting here today, and now,
a word about our speaker, Mr.
Harry Boonin, who received his B.A.
from Pennsylvania State University
and his J.D. from Temple University.
Before retiring, he worked for many
years as a lawyer for the U.S. Navy.
Mr. Boonin devotes much of
his time to Jewish genealogy
and to Philadelphia Jewish history.
He was the founding President
of the Jewish Genealogy Society
of greater Philadelphia, editor of
their newsletter, and was honored
by the Society for
Lifetime Dedication.
Harry has published many articles
in the Jewish Genealogy
Journal of [inaudible].
The book we will hear
about today is his fourth.
Never Tell a Boy Not to Fight
describes the lost world
of Philadelphia Jewish boxing, and
the story of immigrant Jewish boys
who literally fought
their way up from poverty.
One item of business, before
we hear from Mr. Boonin,
this event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal question and
answer period after the lecture,
at which time the audience
is encouraged
to ask questions and offer comments.
Please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the question and
answer period, you are consenting
to the library's possible
reproduction
and transmission of your remarks.
And now, please join me in
welcoming Mr. Harry Boonin.
Oh, one more thing-there are
questionnaires asking for feedback
that are going to be distributed.
If not on your chair, they will be.
So if you could fill them out and
hand them in before you leave,
that would be appreciated, and
also the book, Never Tell a Boy Not
to Fight is for sale in the back,
and Mr. Boonin will be very happy
to sign them if anybody wants.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you for the very nice
introductions, and welcome,
you all, on such a beautiful day.
A question about letters
has been brought up,
whether I ever got any letters.
Well, that shows you how little I
knew when I started about boxers.
Boxers wear eight ounce gloves, and
I guess they can't write letters
with their gloves on [laughs],
but boxers do not write letters,
which is a big disappointment, if
any of you want to be a biographer,
make sure that the
person you're writing
about writes letters,
or writes something.
It's difficult without
them, without the diary.
How did I get into this?
Twenty-four years ago, I was working
for the Navy, and I found myself
in London one day, London,
England, and I had a few hours off.
And I decided to take a walking
tour of the old east end of London.
It was a wonderful tour.
I thought I would do the same thing
when I came back to Philadelphia.
Nobody was doing it.
I started them, and I
did it for 15 years.
And what came out of it was a
book called The Jewish Quarter
of Philadelphia.
And when I finished the
book, I was frustrated
because I felt I really
hadn't told the full story
of the Jewish Quarter, and the
Russian Jews who settled there.
So I wrote a second book,
about a Synagogue of the area,
and the synagogue, I was surprised
to find, had parents, three parents,
that had sons who were
professional boxers.
And I though that was odd, whether
it was or not, I'm not sure.
Then I found out that one of
the premiere boxing managers
in Philadelphia was also
a member of the synagogue.
So I finished the synagogue
book, and I thought I was done,
but the boxers fascinated me.
I was intrigued.
And I thought I would do
a little bit of research,
and see if there was a possibility
that a book could be written.
I found out that Philadelphia,
a century ago,
had many dozen professional boxers.
In 1928, there were more
Jewish boxers for an ethnicity
than any other ethnicity
in the United States.
It only lasted a short time, and
I guess that put me over the top.
And I said, well, I guess
three books make a trilogy,
and I started on my boxing book.
It took eight years.
And this is basically the story.
Let me get started.
This photograph comes from
the Library of Congress,
and it is from the Association
of Newsboys, from Cincinnati.
It's a very interesting
picture, for many reasons.
A lot of the Jewish newsboys in
Philadelphia were not lucky enough
to have any kind of training
like this, but this seems
to be, to be a training room.
The boys, some of the boys
you'll see, are in bare feet.
Other boys have shoes on.
You'll notice, there's
no adults in the room.
And the boys are learning
from each other.
The remarkable part
about this picture is,
if there are both African
American and white boys together,
and they seem, from the picture,
to have been getting along,
and learning, and concentrating,
despite all of the prejudice
that existed around
them at that time.
In fact, if you'll look on the
right-hand side of your screen, I...
[ Inaudible ]
>> There is a-one of the larger
boys, is standing next to,
on his right, a white boy,
and he has his hand gently
on the boy's shoulder,
and you can see
from this little fact,
how close the boys were.
They were intently, and
you can see in their eyes,
how intently they are in learning.
This next picture comes
from Philadelphia,
and again involves the boys.
Newsboys, a lot of Jews
were newsboys at that time.
I was unable to find any kind of
study in Philadelphia, Cincinnati,
or New York, but I did find a
study of newsboys in Denver,
Colorado, a few years later.
And of the 250 newsboys
that were studied,
125 or half of them were Jewish,
which I found really
surprising in Denver, Colorado.
This particular picture
shows, on the left-hand side,
you'll see there's a girl
on a swing, and if you look
in the middle, in the back,
there's a single girl,
who is reading a book, but in
the front, there are two boys,
who are practicing the art of
boxing, the manly art of boxing,
and the teacher doesn't seem
to be interfering with them.
She's letting it go.
So this was something today,
you would see a baseball game,
maybe the kids are playing
ball against the wall,
but what is what the
kids practiced then.
To get into boxing, in Philadelphia,
which is probably like all the towns
in the eastern part
of the United States,
one of the most unusual
venues was called a cyclorama.
And the picture of it is here.
This picture is stated
it was taken in 1887,
and this is where the first
Jewish fighter fought.
A cyclorama is a painting
that is mounted on the inside
of a round building, the
battle of Gettysburg is one
of the most popular cycloramas after
the Civil War, and you can see it
if you go-has anybody here
gone to the Gettysburg Museum?
The new museum opened up.
They have a cyclorama up there.
And it has 20,000-20,000
life-sized figures.
The building on the right
is the same building,
it's painted white here, it's
called the Winter Circus.
This was converted
from the cyclorama
to the Winter Circus
for boxing in 1893.
First, there were Vaudeville
shows here,
and after the Vaudeville shows,
the interest wanted in the city,
and the manager thought he
would try to bring in boxing.
One of the boxers he
brought in was Jewish.
This is a famous painting.
You may recognize the
painting by Thomas Eakins.
Eakins painted it in 1898,
and it was in the interior
of the same building.
You can see in this painting
on the left-hand side,
you'll see there's a press
box, right above the policeman
who is standing there, in the
press box were three journalists,
I guess you'd call
them sports writers,
although they didn't really call
them sports writers at that time,
because it wasn't a profession,
and a fellow that named the round,
and then they also had
a telegraph operator.
So if you were a boxing manager, and
you wanted to get your story out,
you didn't have to go
to a telegraph office,
you could do it right
from the boxing arena.
The fellow in the foreground is
the timekeeper, and you can see
that the ropes in the
ring are already a foot
or more inside the raised
platform that they fought on.
So if the fellow was knocked through
the ropes, he didn't fall right away
onto the floor, which is quite a
fall, but he would fall on the edge,
and hopefully stay
within the platform.
This is a fellow, that is Henry
Pinkus [assumed spelling],
who was the first promoter
at the Winter Circus.
He was also an inventor, filed six
patents at the Library of Congress,
and remained in the fight game
until he ended up being arrested.
In 1898, the fight game was still
considered semi-legal in some towns,
and completely illegal in others.
He finally had enough, and he
left Philadelphia for New York.
This is a picture of the
first Jewish fighter.
He had 60 professional
Jewish fights.
He fought from 1893 to 1905.
His name was Izzy Strauss.
But they called him
the Hebrew Cyclone.
Both of those words would have been
a surprise to the boxing public
and to the general public.
First of all, most Jews
were not known as Hebrews,
and that was to give him sort of an
aura of maybe a Biblical warrior,
rather than a street Jew.
They called him the Hebrew.
The Cyclone-some boxers, many
black boxers were named Cyclone
because he kept his arms
moving all the time.
So this was the Hebrew Cyclone.
He had 60 fights.
Of the 60 fights, there
were 10 disqualifications.
At that time, the press did not
write about anti-Semitism in boxing
or in baseball, so you have to
sort of use your imagination,
which is not a good way to
write a book or to tell a story,
but the ten disqualifications,
none of them were explained.
Strauss bit his opponent, kicked his
opponent, and wrestled his opponent
to the ground, but not one
of the reporters who looked
into these disqualifications
stated why they happened,
and so we just have our
imagination to go on.
And this is where radio biography,
letters, could be so important
or a diary, where the person
would admit what happened.
But the newspapers were not going
to admit anti-Semitism at this time,
at least in Philadelphia.
In other towns they did.
Philadelphia was very proper, and
everything went on on the Q-T.
The next story I'm going to tell you
will be partially my imagination,
probably 100% of what
happened in a fight
on June the 15th, 1906,
in Philadelphia.
This is a picture of the
National Boxing Club,
where the story takes place.
To tell you the story, I'd like to
take you back, both chronologically
and geographically to Russia.
Almost all the fighters who
fought at this time either came
from Russia, or were born to
parents who came from Russia.
And I'll take you back to a little
schechtel [phonetic spelling]
in the southern part of
Russia, in the fall of 1905.
That fall, in the south of Russia,
there were 657 Pogrums
[phonetic spelling].
Pogrums were organized attaché
by the government and the police
and the army against the Jewish
citizens of different towns.
In our imagined story, the
fellow comes out of the house,
his spouse is inside, his children
are hiding in terror under the bed.
The Pogrum crowd has just
destroyed the town and left,
and he goes outside
to look at the street.
The street is muddy.
In the street are all the broken
furniture, from the Pogrum,
and on top of the broken
furniture, the Pogrum chicks,
the Russians who liked to
make Pogrums against Jews,
had cut open all the feather
pillows that they could find,
and spread them all over, and
these were one of the-this is one
of the marks that they left
when the Pogrum was over.
And he thought to himself,
"What am I doing here?
I'm going to tell my
spouse, and tell my kids,
we're getting out of here."
That fall, he sold his
belongings, had enough money
to get a train ticket, and he
left what my uncle called dark
and miserable Russia for
a new land, a golden land.
They traveled by train to Hamburg.
When you got to Hamburg
in those days, remember,
this is the winter of 1906.
You were two miles from the ship.
You had to walk, with your
family, and you had little babies,
so everybody had to carry a baby
in their luggage, two
miles to the ship.
The ship went across the North Sea
in winter, a very rough crossing,
to Grimsbere Hull, in the east
coast of Britain, and from there,
they crossed by rail to Liverpool,
and Liverpool took
them to Philadelphia.
In Philadelphia, this would
be in January or February
in this hypothetical story,
they settled where all
of the immigrants settled
at that time.
This would be January
or February of 1906.
That was the one year where the
Jews had 125,000 immigrants.
Immigrant Jews who came from Russia,
the largest immigration of any year
in our history or in
Russian history.
He got a job in one
of the sweat shops.
The sweat shops at
that time operated
with 39 different functions.
You were taught one function-sew
the buttons on the collar.
Sew the buttons on the shirt.
And that is what you did all day.
It could be taught, you
didn't have to know English.
Everyone in the sweat
shop spoke Yiddish,
and that is what he learned.
He noticed, after a few months
there, now we're into May and June
of 1906, that the other men in the
shop, who were speaking Yiddish,
were talking about a prize fight,
and he didn't know
what a prize fight was.
And they told him, the two men get
in a ring, and in a certain number
of rounds, they try
to win the fight.
Well, there was a-he felt, well,
maybe the best thing for me
to do is go to a fight and
see what goes on there.
All the fellows in the shop
seemed to-you could buy a ticket
for a quarter.
He said, "I just won't tell my wife
about spending a quarter on this,
and I'll go over there Friday night.
Maybe she'll think I
went to synagogue."
He woke up the morning of 15 June
1906, and reading the headlines,
the fellows in the shop
who could read English,
discovered there was a
Pogrum, in Bialystok, Poland.
And normally, in Philadelphia,
when there was a large Pogrum,
they had protest meetings
in all of the synagogues
in the southern part
of Philadelphia.
So he then had a choice between
going to synagogue that night,
and attending the protest
meetings or going to the fight.
And he said, "If I'm going
to be a real American,
and understand what
this country is about,
I'm going to go to the prize fight.
So he went to the National
Boxing Club, which we see here.
And he went inside.
When he got inside, he looked
around, and he wondered,
"I wonder who all these people are?
Are they Jews?
Are they Jews like me?
Or are they other people?"
And he couldn't quite determine who
they were, because unlike Russia,
where the peasants and the Jews
wore much different clothing,
in the United States it was hard to
discern by clothing who anyone was.
And then the fighters came out.
The first fighter to come out is
one of the most popular fighters
who ever fought in
the United States.
His name was Joe Gans.
I don't know if anybody
ever heard his name.
Today, he is not well-known,
but in 1906,
there was no heavyweight champion.
Jim Jeffries had just retired, and
Gans was the lightweight champion,
and the lightweight division
in those days was considered the
second most interesting behind
the heavyweights.
Gans was to die of tuberculosis
four years after this,
but I think he was the
most popular fighter,
black or white, at that time.
And he has always been considered
one of the best fighters,
pound for pound, who ever
fought in the United States.
I want to go back.
He fought against a Jew by
the name of Harry Lewis.
And Lewis' real name was Besterman.
Lewis had had 77 fights before
this, but never met anyone
of the caliber of Joe Gans.
Joe Gans was a lightweight champion,
and this was not a
championship fight.
But the national AC,
that night, June 15,
1906, was completely filled.
There were 5,000 people
in the-at the club.
Just to compare that, the Chicago
Cubs of 1906, who finally went
through World Series, but
didn't win it that year,
but won it the next year, and
with the double-play combination
of tinkers averaged a chance,
they could only draw 4,000 people
to the ballpark to
play the Phillies,
where this boxing match drew 5,000.
The first thing that our imagined
attendee thought was, in Russia,
a Jew couldn't be an
official street sweeper,
an official street
sweeper-and here he is looking
up that this is fellow, Harry Lewis,
is eligible to fight the
lightweight champion.
He happens to be an African
American, but what stuck
in our imagined fellow's
mind is, that as a Jew,
he has a right to fight him.
And so he recognized right
away not in a courtroom,
not in a naturalization ceremony,
but the equality that exists
at the lowest level of American
society, and he liked it.
The fight went six rounds.
At that time, they were
six-round fights in Philadelphia.
When Gans and Lewis went in
the ring, they shook hands,
and he took note of that.
But when the fight was over,
and it was more or less a draw,
the fighters shook hands again
and smiled at one another,
and that meant a lot to him, that
there were two diverse ethnicities,
if you call it that, who could
get along with each other,
even after they pummeled
each other for six rounds.
Neither one was particularly hurt,
and Harry Lewis' name
then skyrocketed,
because everyone felt it.
Although he did not win the fight
he had put up a wonderful battle
and that he would go
far in the boxing game.
Harry Lewis is one of the
stories that's in the book.
For you who read old newspapers, you
may be familiar with illustrations.
They had photographs.
This is the illustration
of that fight.
And they illustrated-the cartoonist
illustrated people the way they saw
them, or the way their editor
wanted them to be portrayed.
If you wanted them to show a
minority in an unfavorable light,
you could take an African
American and paint his lips thick.
You could take a Jew and
give him a Jewish nose.
Either one of those things would
accomplish what the editor wanted,
and that's what the paper wanted,
I won't name the paper [laughs].
This is another cartoonist,
by the name of Tad Dorgan.
I don't know if the name Tad
Dorgan means anything to anybody,
but he is very famous today.
He is a coiner of phrases.
He coined them back when
he was a boxing writer,
and he was a very fair man.
Here's an illustration
of the same two fighters,
but there is no derogatory
pen marks in his drawing.
Gans on the right is shown as
hitting Lewis in the stomach,
while avoiding or slipping
Lewis' right hand,
which goes harmlessly
over his shoulder.
But both men are pictured
like they are.
Lewis, a little bit on the heavy
side, Gans slightly angular.
And it is a better picture of
what they really look like.
This is one of the few really
interesting and subtle,
or not too subtle, depending
on how you look at it,
ideas of the Tale of the Tape.
A Tale of the Tape is
usually a measurement
of the fighter's different parts of
his anatomy, such as biceps, legs,
ankles, and things like that.
And you read down, and the only
line that is of some interest,
of great interest, is the last line.
Now, this is the Tale of the Tape,
and they always stop at ankle.
They didn't stop at ankle, it went
to nationality, and the fellow
on the left, Howard Baker, was
identified as an Irish American.
Well, you would think the fellow
on the right would be
identified as a Jewish American.
I won't ask you the question why
they identified him as a Jew.
But they did identify
in the narrative
that Howard Baker had baby
skin and a blonde pompadour,
so those were two very
relevant factors
to the boxing match [laughs].
I'm going to skip that.
Harry Lewis later went over to
France, and fought in France,
and this is a battle he had
with Georges Carpentier,
who was a famous French fighter,
and a famous French flier
in the first world war.
This picture, I love
this picture from 1913.
This is a drugstore in London, and
it has two pictures on the left.
One of the pictures
is all in Yiddish.
One of the pictures in Yiddish
says "Rabbi attacked by Shiksa,"
and the two papers on the right
are papers about American fights.
So out of the seven papers that are
shown in front of this drug store,
some of them have to do with
Yiddish or they are in Yiddish,
and the other two had
to do with boxing,
to show you how popular
boxing was in London in 1913.
The fellow on the left
is one of the Jews
in Philadelphia they
did not write about,
but he won the lightweight title,
and the junior lightweight title,
and the featherweight
title in the 1920s.
This is Lew Tendler.
Lew Tendler was a most
famous-I don't know
if his name means anything here
in Washington-in Philadelphia
almost everybody knows him
like people know Jack
Dempsey in New York.
Lew Tendler, after he
retired, opened a restaurant.
In fact, he's the one
who gave Dempsey the idea
of opening a restaurant,
and they both were
in the restaurant business
for 25 years.
When there were big fights in
Philadelphia, like all the fights
of Jersey Joe Walcott, and Marciano
in the early 50s, and Joe Lewis,
all the writers from New York would
come down to Tendler's restaurant.
Everybody gathered there.
It was a great meeting place
for writers, and a great place
for writers to get the
material for their stories.
They may not have had letters,
but they knew where to go
to find Broadway characters, and
it wasn't on Broadway [laughs].
One of the favorites in
Tendler's was David Runyon.
David Runyon was always there.
It's a story that he
was told by Hurst,
he worked for William Randolph
Hurst, covering the 1936 convention,
when Roosevelt was
nominated, and eventually won,
but he should get to Philadelphia.
Since Roosevelt was such a shoe-in
at the Democratic Convention,
David Runyon spent the whole time,
the whole week of the convention
at Tendler's restaurant, and it goes
on to say all the stories he wrote.
He wrote a story called
Little Miss Marker,
and I don't know if
you've ever seen it.
That was made into a movie
and starred Shirley Temple,
and that was one of her roles
that really shot her to fame.
This is the street that Tendler
was born on in Philadelphia.
Years later, that's one
of his first fighters.
When Tendler fought another Jewish
fighter, they were both Jewish,
they got in the ring, and
they couldn't hit each other,
they just couldn't do it, so there
were 4,000 people in the arena
and by the second round, there were
2,000 people, by the third round,
there was about a dozen people
left, because it was a fake.
When the reporters
went into the room
to ask Tendler what was
this all about, he cried.
So sometimes, we think of players
as being really tough guys,
but it doesn't mean a
tough guy can't cry.
This is another one of his fights.
This is Tendler in training.
He trained at a millionaire's
mansion.
How he wrangled this, I couldn't
quite figure out, but the guy was
such a nice guy, he had a 21-- - 28
room mansion, and when Tendler came
to prepare for a fight, he put
every one of Tendler's people,
there were 28 of them, he
gave them each a Victrola,
so they could play music
before they went to bed.
This is another boxing venue in
Philadelphia, and that's a picture
of it empty, this is
a picture of it full.
And these are taken
in the early 1920s.
This you can't see too much of,
but Benny Leonard was
a lightweight champion,
probably the best Jewish
fighter there ever was.
And these are the people
celebrating.
In the picture you can see a
snare drum, a bass drum, clarinet,
and even a violin [laughs]
and letters at the top.
This is a picture at the
place where he was training,
Tendler always had a ukulele,
but this is not a ukulele,
it looks to me like
a banjo [laughs],
and I don't know-he's
playing it left handed.
Can you play a banjo left handed?
You don't have to answer that.
These are some of the
guys-Tendler was never seen alone.
He was a great guy-a great fellow.
And he takes up over half the book.
The stories are wonderful.
This is my favorite picture
of him in the newspaper,
my son the fighter, and you
can see who the mother is,
and who the fighter
is in this picture.
The two men in the back were
his brothers, and the person
on the left is the sister.
All four of them have their
arms around the youngest member.
This was something
that Tendler handed
out at his restaurant, of advice.
It has all the advice, and
I know you can't read it,
but the last line says...the last
line, the last-the greatest thing
in all the world, bar none, is love.
That was the way he felt.
He gave out 300,000 of these free.
There are postcards
on the other side.
And this is the last picture.
This picture was taken about a
month after the book came out,
and it's sort of like
an archaeological dig,
because everybody in Philly
saw this, that they knocked
down a parking garage, next to
where Tendler's restaurant was,
and lo and behold, there was a sign
that said Tendler's restaurant.
Nobody had heard of it or thought
of it in the last 20 or 30 years.
They closed in 1970.
That's 46 years ago.
So it made quite a hit.
So that's the story
of the book on boxing.
Sorry I didn't have more
time to talk to you,
but I'd love to take any
questions that you have.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Who were the trainers?
All boxers, who trained
them for the boxing matches?
Who trained these young
men to become boxers?
>> The question is who
prepared-in other words,
was there an organization?
Was this organized?
>> Was this organized
with the trainers or?
>> Okay, boxing was
very unorganized.
That's a very good question.
In 1905, in 1906, there were 16
boxers who were killed in the ring.
And I knew there were
problems in football,
and a lot of the articles said
that boxing is not as rough,
or more rough than football,
and I wondered just how
rough football was in 1906.
Looking it up, ironically,
what I found was there were 16
football players in 1905 and 1906.
I continued, and I
looked up horse racing,
and I found out there were 16
jockeys who were killed in 1906,
eight of them on a horse, the other
8 were killed in other incidents.
So there was a lot of-there
was danger in all the sports,
but football was organized,
to answer your question,
and football addressed the
flying wedge in different forms
of football, to lessen the danger.
The way the deaths in
boxing were handled was
that they would handle
it as a criminal matter.
And Lewis, Harry Lewis, and I spent
a lot of time in the book on this,
Harry Lewis actually
killed a man in the ring,
and they charged him with murder.
So that's-that's what boxing got,
because they weren't organized.
You asked the question about
who arranged the matches.
The matches were arranged by
whoever was the best negotiator.
Each boxer had someone looking out
for them, somebody in the family,
or he had no one looking out for
him, and looked out for himself.
Most of those guys got
taken advantage of.
But there was an awful lot
of skullduggery in boxing,
probably was in football
and baseball too [laughs],
I didn't write about them.
But I don't know if that
quite answers your question,
but I would say it was basically an
unorganized sport, and no one tried
to organize it before 1915.
By 1930s, when prohibition was
being phased out, and the mafia
and different gangs felt there
was money to be made in boxing,
then the criminal element
entered boxing in a big way,
at the management and
promotional level.
Yes sir?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Could you speak a little louder?
>> At one point in this
century did Jewish involvement
in boxing start to taper off?
>> That's a good question.
The question is at what point in
this century did Jewish boxing tend
to taper off, and the
answer to that is,
when Congress passed the quota
act in 1924, up until 1924,
there was another quota act in
1921, but in 24, they cut off all,
for practical purposes,
immigration from Russia.
Almost all of the fighters
did it for money.
were poor.
And all of the fighters knew
that if their father had died,
like Tendler's father, somebody had
to make the money for the family,
and they could make a
lot more money fighting
than they could being newsboys.
He was a newsboy, and a
fighter, both at the same time.
And so beginning in 1924,
there was no more immigration.
So then the boys that were being
brought up, the Jewish boys,
felt that gee, this boxing
thing is kind of rough,
maybe I'm better off going to
college, or something like that,
and becoming a lawyer,
becoming a doctor.
If this is really an open country,
and we know there were restrictions
at Harvard and different
ivy league schools,
that it might still be a better
risk than getting in the ring
and getting my brains knocked out.
So it started to drop off
as far as new young boxers,
I would say, in the early 1930s.
But during the 1930s, they still
had full-grown Jewish boxers,
in the 1920s.
But if you went to a
training ring at that time,
there would be no young boys, six or
seven, looking up at their heroes.
There would be none of those,
because there were no immigrants.
In 1906, I think I mentioned,
there were 125,000 Jews from Russia
who came to the United States.
In 1933, there were 2,000.
That is how effective the
quota act of 1924 was.
And then, everybody knows the
story, when Hitler came to power.
Any other questions?
Well, I thank you all
very much for inviting me,
and hope you enjoyed the talk.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.